In der Schule
war ich nicht so gut in Chemie.
Ich bin ein bisschen nervös.
- Waaaah!
* Titelmusik *
Herzlich willkommen!
Heute wieder: Chemie in der Küche.
Ich hab mir Verstärkung geholt.
Das ist: - Florian.
Florian ist ein Funk-Kollege.
Er macht das Format Hochkant.
Hochkant sind News und Reportagen
auf Snapchat und Instagram.
Wenn euch ein bisschen interessiert,
was in der Welt los ist:
Ich erzähl's euch auf Hochkant,
addet Hochkant
auf Snapchat und Instagram.
Flo, warum bist du heute hier?
Weil du gesagt hast, wir machen
Pulver aus Schokoaufstrich.
Das will ich mir
nicht entgehen lassen.
Ich hab schon was vorbereitet,
wir sind in meiner Küche.
Wir werden damit experimentieren:
Maltodextrin.
Maltodextrin. - Jawoll.
- Hast du das schon mal gehört?
Ich stell mir das vor wie so...
Proteinpulver.
Das hier... ist ein Zucker.
Dieser eine Zucker,
wenn man diesen Strich durchzeichnet
und die Klammer...
nee, ich muss noch mal anfangen.
Dieser eine Zucker
wäre Traubenzucker.
Nur das in der Klammer
ist Traubenzucker. - Genau.
Es gibt Einfachzucker,
Zweifachzucker,
z.B.Haushaltszucker ist
ein Zweifachzucker, Saccharose.
Wenn man davon viele
aneinander hängt in einer Kette,
dann haben wir ein Polysaccharid.
Also Poly-, Mehrfachzucker
oder auch Kohlenhydrat.
Zucker ist erstens süß und
zweitens wasserlöslich, richtig? -Ja.
Stärke kann ich nicht
in Wasser lösen.
Was fürs Wasser wichtig ist,
sind diese OH-Gruppen.
Die verstehen sich gut mit Wasser.
Man sagt hydrophil.
D.h.so viel wie wasserliebend.
Wenn viele OH- Gruppen da sind,
löst sich das im Wasser problemlos.
Was passiert, wenn man das
immer länger macht? Gucken wir mal.
Wenn das nur ein Zucker wäre,
Traubenzucker,
hätten wir pro Ring
1, 2, 3, 4, 5 OH-Gruppen.
Der Ring ist aber,
wir sagen hydrophob.
Das sind Kohlenstoffatome.
Die verstehen sich
nicht so gut mit Wasser.
Wenn wir aus einem zwei machen,
das wäre Maltose.
Dann haben wir zwei Ringe,
aber nicht die doppelte Zahl
von OH-Gruppen.
Nicht zehn, sondern nur acht.
Wir haben in der Klammer drei,
mal zwei sind sechs und zwei am Ende.
Das Verhältnis von hydrophob,
von Ringen zu OH-Gruppe,
wird immer größer.
D.h.je länger ich die Kette mache,
irgendwann überwiegen
die hydrophoben Eigenschaften.
Dann löst es sich
nicht mehr in Wasser.
Maltodextrin ist zwischen Glukose
und Stärke irgendwo in der Mitte.
Wenn es dazwischen ist,
ist es nur ein bisschen süß?
Oder ist Maltodextrin gar nicht süß?
Es ist so'n ganz bisschen süß.
Maltodextrin
ist immerhin so hydrophob,
dass es Fett und Öl absorbiert.
Irgendwie benutzt man das z.B.,
um Olivenöl-Powder zu machen.
Um fettige Flüssigkeiten
in Pulver zu überführen.
Maltodextrin saugt das Fett und
die Aromen auf und verschließt sie.
Aber sobald das Pulver in den Mund
kommt, löst es sich in Wasser auf.
Und setzt sofort die Aromen
und das Fett frei.
Das werden wir heute versuchen.
Mir läuft schon das Wasser
im Mund zusammen.
Ich hab hier ca. 240g Nuss-Nougat-
Creme, gemischt mit Schoko-Creme.
Butter ist auch noch drin.
- Ja. (lacht)
Ich hab das angemischt
und hatte das Gefühl,
da ist noch nicht genug Fett drin.
Deswegen hab ich Butter reingemacht.
Mit YouTube hab ich angefangen
während der... die Butter!
Ich find, es sieht sehr gut aus.
Hier hab ich, ich glaub,
das sind 160g Maltodextrin.
Alles, was man machen muss, ist,
das z.B.in einen Mixer zu geben
und es richtig gut
physikalisch zu malträtieren.
Hmmm. Das sieht doch schon super aus.
Das ist 'ne kleine Sauerei,
soll ich mit dem Löffel...?
Ach, ist egal, komm.
Das ist die gute alte Funk-Maschine.
Ihr wisst, wir werden bei Funk
in Küchenmaschinen bezahlt.
Ich weiß nicht,
wie viele du schon hast.
Sehr viele, vor allem viele rosane.
* Mixer brummt *
Ok, das hat schon mal
nicht funktioniert.
* Mixer brummt lauter *
Boah, das ist voll heiß.
- Uiuiui.
Jetzt explodiert gleich
die Küchenmaschine.
Jetzt zieht's aus, als ob
das beides zusammengemischt ist.
So richtig was anderes ist
noch nicht entstanden, oder? - Nee.
Vielleicht ist von irgendwas zu viel.
Die Butter war das Problem,
ich hätte nicht noch mal
Butter reinmachen sollen.
Ich hab eher das Gefühl,
man braucht mehr Fett.
Aber das ist nur
mein laienhaftes Gefühl.
Ich glaube, wir sollten
das Gegenteil von dem machen,
was ich denke.
Du bist der Chemie-Crack.
Ich würd vom Gefühl her sagen,
wir brauchen mehr Pulver.
Machen wir noch ein bisschen dazu.
* Mixer brummt *
Was wir versuchen,
hat bisher nicht geklappt.
Vielleicht ists nur 'ne Frage der
richtigen physikalischen Bearbeitung.
Jetzt passiert noch mal
was ganz anderes.
Ich glaub, ich bin für Knetwedel
für das große Zeug.
* Gelächter *
Ich glaub, sie ist kaputt.
- Wirklich?
Alles ok, Küchenmaschine?
Also, Funk, ich brauche
eine neue Küchenmaschine.
Ich glaub, das ist es.
Und?
- Ja, schön warm.
Hallo. - Hallo, Flo.
Na, alles gut?
- Also, pass auf.
Ich bin am Schneiden des Videos.
Ich bin schon fast fertig.
Und die Aufnahme
stoppt in dem Moment,
wo wir die Löffel in die Hand nehmen,
um das zu probieren.
Die Zeit war einfach drüber.
- Ach, shit.
Das Gute ist, dass die Zuschauer
nicht viel verpasst haben.
Es hatte nichts damit zu tun,
dass das Pulver im Mund
schlagartig zerfließt, zerschmilzt
und eine Geschmacksexplosion auslöst.
Das ist leider überhaupt nicht
passiert. - Das ist nicht passiert.
Ihr habt nichts verpasst.
Was ist jetzt besser,
Nuss-Nougat-Creme
oder Nuss-Nougat-Creme-Pulver?
Das Bessere ist auf jeden Fall
die gute alte Nuss-Nougat-Creme,
wie wir sie kennen.
- Ja, viel besser.
Die schmeckt wirklich viel besser.
Wir haben ein ganzes Glas
Nuss-Nougat-Creme verschleudert.
Und deine Küchenmaschine
kaputt gemacht.
Das ist die zweite gute Nachricht:
Die Küchenmaschine geht wieder.
Gott sei Dank.
Wie wär's, wenn wir...
hörst du das?
...die Packung Maltodextrin verlosen?
Dann kann das irgendjemand
ganz, ganz viel ausprobieren.
Ja, und hoffentlich
viel besser als wir.
Das ist tatsächlich die Packung,
die Flo und ich benutzt haben.
D.h.sie ist angebrochen,
aber das meiste von diesem Kilo
Maltodextrin ist noch drin.
Wenn ihr Bock habt,
euch auszuprobieren,
schreibt in die Kommentare,
dass ihr das haben möchtet und warum.
Der Kommentar mit der besten Antwort
kriegt das zugeschickt.
Alle weiteren Infos in der Infobox.
Wenn ihr bei Snapchat
oder Instagram seid,
schaut nach Flo von Hochkant.
Ich bin übrigens auch auf Instagram,
ihr müsst mir folgen.
Es passieren viele tolle Dinge,
die ihr verpasst.
Schätzeleins, ihr wisst Bescheid:
Schönschlau, bleibt sicher.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)